pour fabriquer sa bière tout commence
avec une céréale le malt
c'est vraiment ce qui va donner notre
base de céréales ce qui va donner la
couleur de notre bière ce qui va donner
le profil gustatif de notre de notre
bière et au final c'est aussi ce qui va
créer du sucre ou ce qui va nous créer
ce que va nous créer l'alcool chez
oakbrook la brasserie artisanale monté
par une bande de trois copains à bois
d'arcy il ya trois ans on utilise un
panel d'une quinzaine de malte
différents qui sont concassés dans son
moulin faut qu on va sélectionner notre
notre grand con la concassée
l'idée c'est de faire venir tout le
grain qu'on a stocké là bas jusqu'à
cette cuve ici qui est notre cube
d'empaquetage
donc c'est ici où on va réellement
brasser les graines sont mélangés à de
l'eau chaude à 65 degrés celsius pendant
une heure et demie lorsque l'infusion
est terminée le rinçage commence pour
s'assurer que tous les grains soit entré
en contact avec le liquide avant de
passer à l'émulation après filtration
une fois qu'on a notre note liquide qui
est rentré en ébullition on va commencer
à faire nos premiers houblonnage sachant
que les houblons plus on va les utiliser
tôt pendant cette ébullition et plus ils
vont donner de l'amertume après avoir
brillé pendant une heure et demie le
liquide est stérile et il faut utiliser
un refroidisseur pour faire baisser sa
température
une fois qu'on l'a refroidi on vient
positionner notre mykid à l'intérieur de
ces de ces cubes que vous avez derrière
derrière moi qu'ils sont des fermenteurs
et une fois tout notre notre liquide a
été refroidie et qu'il est rentré à
l'inter de sécu à 20 degrés on va ainsi
miné la bière c'est à dire qu'on va lui
ajoutez des levures les levures agit
cependant cette étape de fermentation
leur travail de manger le sucré et
l'alcool et le co2 qui rendra la bière
pétillante l'accusent passe ensuite de
20 à 0 degrés pour la dernière étape de
garde au froid dont cambo pour fabriquer
une bière on va avoir une journée de
fabrication une semaine de fermentation
et 3 semaines 2
deux gardes qui fait une tube allaient
monopoliser pendant à peu près un mois
une fois qu'elle a été
quelle a été brassé chez o clock le
brassage se fait deux à trois fois par
semaine en fonction des cuves disponible
pour varier les plaisirs
les 3 brasseurs développe aussi une
gamme de bières vieilli en barriques
pour nous l'idée c'est pas d'acheter des
barriques neuves c'est d'acheter des
barriques qui ont déjà servi qui ont
déjà une histoire et de profiter de
l'histoire de ces barriques ici sont
stockés 40 baril qui vont faire leur
travail pendant six mois un nom pour des
bières aux arrière-goût d'alcool plus
fort
les biarrots clock sont distribués dans
des bars et des revendeurs indépendants
en france et en europe mais aussi dans
leurs propres boutiques avec une gamme
de 12 à 15 bières différentes qui varie
chaque semaine la première année on
était même un peu surpris que la bière
était réellement quelque chose qu'on
pouvait qu'on pouvait offrir à noël
cette année ils ont même développé un
calendrier de l'avent et une gamme à
offrir et nous ce qu'on propose pour
pour noël c'est un petit pack de un
petit pack de bières avec six bouteilles
dans lequel vous avez les cinq best
seller de la brasserie qui est complété
par notre part notre bière de noël notre
christmas bay
et qui emballée dans un paquet cadeau
avec le descriptif de toutes nos de tout
mobilières la france est le troisième
pays européen en nombre de brasseries
derrière l'allemagne et le royaume uni